well we begin this newshour in
afghanistan where
gun battles have been taking place
inside kabul university
after multiple attackers entered that
campus
now some students are understood to
still be inside
police have cordoned off the area and
also closed the main road leading to
that campus
the taliban says its fighters are not
responsible for that raid
well let's now go live to akbar shinwari
he's in
the afghan capital kabul for us akbar
tell us a little bit about this
developing situation i know it's really
fast moving what do we know at this
stage
indeed it's a it's a developed situation
here in afghanistan in kabul
a group of gunmen entered the kabul
university compound this morning
and they started gunfire inside the
university compound
while the students were visiting their
classroom according to the minister of
interior the avant special forces
arrived at the scene and called enough
the area uh the avant special forces
were able to evacuate most of the
students
from the university compound but we are
told by some of the students that's
still
trapped inside this university compound
there are no reports of the uh
the tribe uh the the host about these
hospitals
or those students were kept as a hostage
inside the university
on the other hand taliban are are
denying the involvement in this attack
and they said we are not involved in
this attack
uh our unconfirmed report are suggesting
that more than 16 people are killed and
more than 20 are wounded but we are told
by the ministry of
health that they have received only
eight injured people to dear
to their hospitals here in kabul
including a professor from the kabul
university
and akbar do you get the sense from
security forces that they feel that they
are in control of this situation they
know
what's going on and that they will be
able to hold someone to account for this
we are told by one of the uh one of the
security commanders from the area that
said the will
where the security so the situation is
under their control they want to be very
careful
uh to proceed with this operation
because they have a fear to
do not cause more uh casualties there
because there are
students inside this compound and they
do not know the number of the attackers
that how many people are still there but
you are told by by the students that
they're
uh in their classrooms they want to keep
their self
safe there they do not know about the
the number of the attackers in the in in
this compound but they still hear the
the gunfire
inside the university compound akbash
and worry they're on the ground for us
in kabul with all the latest we'll be
staying across that story for you here
on al jazeera thanks so much